un hommage et de l'émotion sur le visage
de michel laugier le tout nouvel élu du
sénat faisait ses premiers adieux au
conseil municipal une instance dans
laquelle il siège depuis 16 ans
successivement directeur de cabinet de
nicolas à bout pendant trois ans et
depuis 2004 maire de montigny le
bretonneux
c'est un mélange de fierté et de bonheur
et de tristesse aussi parce que j'ai là
l'équipe municipale qui est dynamique
qui a toujours été à mes côtés qui cela
a des côtés pour défendre montini pour
faire évoluer cette ville et je regrette
vraiment tu vas te vraiment cette loi
sur le non-cumul le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a désormais un mois pour
démissionner de ses différents mandats
locaux
son départ au sénat grâce à la large
victoire de la droite dans les yvelines
marque un tournant pour la commune de
montigny le bretonneux dans le livre de
montigny il aurait écrit une à chapitre
important c'est une page qui se tourne
et avec un petit peu de et beaucoup même
d'émotions pour nous ils le méritent
biya il a fait
bien évidemment montini un superbe
travail a beau travail à l'agglo
légalement et puis là maintenant je suis
sûr qu'il fera beau travail aussi de son
côté l'opposition a salué aussi
l'élection de son meilleur adversaire
même si leur relation se sont révélés
souvent tendues avec la gauche locale
moi ça a été un élu local de proximité
faut le reconnaître quelqu'un qui a été
très très connue peut être aimé par un
certain nombre d désigné montana il faut
tout à fait le reconnaître maintenant il
a glissé le mot dans son dans son
discours final c'est quelqu'un qui
faisait une carrière c'est quelqu'un qui
a fait une carrière politique
il a dit qu'il va poursuivre sa carrière
politique maintenant au niveau national
les premiers pas de michel logis ausina
sont prévues le 2 octobre prochain
les parlementaires seront réunis pour
l'élection du président de la chambre un
poste clé qui devrait revenir une
nouvelle fois à liv linois gérard
larcher